google is the king of the internet from
google chrome
and youtube to gmail google maps google
drive
google docs google slides and many many
more
they quite literally control the
internet but ironically
the company that has connected the
entire world together and the company
that is infamous for not respecting
personal privacy
wanted to go off the grid not too long
ago with their google island project in
2013.
so what happened to google's off the
grid vision
[Music]
well starting off the idea to take
google's operations
behind closed doors of course came from
one of google's founders
larry page you see larry page and sergey
brin
the founders of google never really
wanted to run a company per se
they were drawn to the internet because
of the opportunity it provided to invent
and innovate from constructing clever
financing mechanisms to offer more email
storage than any of the competition
to funding a large-scale video sharing
platform google has always been more
keen on revolutionizing the internet
than making money
in fact most of google's businesses are
in the red a little
or a lot as virtually all of their
services
are offered for free with little means
to subsidize the cost
for instance with youtube as of may 2019
500 hours of content was uploaded every
single minute
that's the same as 82 years worth of
content every single day
i think it's clear why even with all
those pesky ads
google has had a tough time making
youtube profitable
and this is the same case with google
drive and google maps and all of their
super cheap phones
evidently though google is very much
concerned about running their overall
business profitably
that was never their primary goal at
least not when larry page and sergey
brin were leading the company
when they were in control many observers
described google to be run more like a
research institution
as opposed to a tech company and that's
exactly what they wanted
this was especially true with google's
ex laboratory or their
moonshot factory the google x lab is
where the craziest ideas like the google
car project and google glass were born
and though this was originally just a
small part of the company dedicated to
passion projects
as google started to become a more
stable and dominant player in the early
2010s
larry page wanted more of the company to
participate in a vision he called
the google island he projected this
vision in one of his last public
speaking events
in may of 2013 before he stepped down as
ceo
ideally the vision entailed taking
google private and moving it to a remote
island
though neither of these were really
required to make the vision a reality
what larry page really wanted for google
was freedom from regulation
corporate interests and most importantly
shareholders
larry page felt that our population was
and still is way too negative
and that this is especially true with
the tech community
thus google island would not only give
the company more freedom
but also all of its employees evidently
taking google private and moving into an
island would fulfill all of these
ambitions
but google island is more of a metaphor
as opposed to the actual game plan
larry really just wanted google to be
able to experiment without having to be
accountable
but as you can see this never came to
fruition
so what happened well first of all
google was already a massive corporation
and
taking such a large company private is
nearly impossible
today 300 million shares of the total of
673 million shares outstanding
are float shares in other words these
are the shares that
aren't held by insiders and institutions
who are never going to sell
right now the float percentage is 44.4
and we're talking about a company worth
1.2 trillion dollars
you can see why this would be extremely
difficult to take private
not only would you have to raise 532
billion dollars
but you would have to convince the
majority of shareholders with voting
rights to actually vote on taking the
company private
and i don't think the majority of
shareholders of a reliable
fast-growing tech company would want to
give up their shares willingly
now this wasn't the 2013-2015 time frame
so the capital required to take google
private would have been substantially
lower
but it would be nonetheless upwards of
200 billion dollars
something else to consider is all of the
employees holding shares of the company
if google were to go private none of its
employees could liquidate their stock
compensation
as a result funding was difficult and it
was unlikely that shareholders and
employees would cooperate
aside from this not very many people
took larry page seriously
in the first place the vast majority of
articles that covered the topic made fun
of the idea
suggesting that it was ridiculous and
very unrealistic
on top of this many articles detailed
that the idea was simply more proof of
the gaping distance between regular
people
and mega billionaires while many people
were struggling to get by
larry page was over here talking about a
google utopia
thus larry's vision was often just
written off as billionaire delusion
and that brings us into the other major
shortfall of the plan
which is that larry's previous
quote-unquote delusional ideas
hadn't really done much aside from the
internet and tech space
there's very little if any projects from
google that have really taken off
google started the google car project
way back in 2009
but today tesla is objectively much
further ahead in the autonomy race
despite starting six years later at
least that has made significant progress
there are several google x lab projects
that were completely abandoned
like their jetpack and space elevator
projects this
is to be expected as these are moonshot
ideas
and it's not that big of a deal as the
google empire can easily compensate for
the losses on such projects
but that requires that google's core
business is strong and growing
and there was fear that pursuing the
google island project would hurt
google's core business
considering the significant opposition
to the idea it's no wonder why the idea
didn't gain much momentum
but that doesn't mean that larry page
would give up on the idea
soon after proposing the idea of google
island google would invest into a mucha
company named calico
which is focused on extending human life
since then
we haven't heard very much about the
company's progress in actually extending
human life
but they are still around and i hope
that they are making progress
as this is quite an important endeavor
anyways
going back to larry page though he was
unsuccessful making the entire company
into an island
between 2013 and 2015 larry page would
get google to invest in many companies
like calico
which he believed aligned with his
long-term vision but as you would guess
shareholders weren't exactly pleased
with where all of this money was going
in 2013 during an earnings call a stock
analyst would question the significant
amounts of money google was chucking at
far-off research projects
that had a high likelihood of never
generating any revenue
larry page would reply that the analyst
was thinking too short term
and that he should be asking larry to
spend even more on such projects
after this encounter larry page would
never join an earnings call
again by 2015 however i think larry page
had a realization
it was pretty clear that he couldn't
make google an island
but he could make himself an island
after all
he had tens of billions of dollars and
he could easily fund all of the ideas he
envisioned
himself consequently in 2015
larry page would step down as ceo of
google and
hand over the reign cisgender piche he
would continue to oversee the company as
he made himself the ceo of a holding
company named alphabet
but he would step away from this as well
near the end of 2019
after that we basically never heard from
him again
he does still attend important google
meetings here and there
but he has completely stepped away from
the public relations of google
in the meantime he has turned to funding
a variety of passion projects privately
like you want to google to do for
instance he has been funding a couple of
flying car companies including opener
and kitty hawk
larry page has also poured tens of
millions into tesla over the years
getting as far back as 2006. he has been
a huge supporter of clean energy
and specifically elon musk's work in the
area
in fact larry page has claimed in the
past that he would rather give
all of his money to elon musk than
charity as he thinks his money would
have a bigger impact with elon
meanwhile the outlook at google isn't
looking nearly as bright
don't get me wrong here their stock
price has grown several fold since larry
left
and they're more profitable than ever
before
but it seems like the inventive spirit
of google is starting to fade away
employees are beginning to suggest that
google's open culture may be closing
and just last year google dropped out
the top 10 places to work after
dominating the list for
years though larry and sergey's
departure hasn't affected the bottom
line
it does seem to have subdued the culture
of google
at the end of the day larry page dreamed
of taking google off the grid
as he thought that this would be the
most effective way to invent and
innovate
however strong backlash from
shareholders and the media as well as
financial restrictions
prevented his dream from evolving into
reality despite this
larry page did try his best to refocus
google targets before stepping down
by investing into various companies that
he thought were important
today though he was unsuccessful at
transforming google
he himself has become the so-called
google island
as he sits back off the grid just
investing in whatever he thinks
is right what do you guys think about
the google island
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys hope that larry's
investments pay off in the future
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
you